Let's say it's a lovely Tuesday evening
and you're out there living your best
life, building a new commander deck from
the comfort of your couch. You start by
finding cards. Maybe they're from EDRE.
Maybe they're from Scrifall Searches.
And maybe they're from your friend Brad,
who happens to be an expert on for
toughness creatures. Regardless, you're
finding lots of cool stuff for your
deck, and you're tossing them into some
sort of deck building website, watching
them neatly segregate themselves by card
type before your very eyes. This is fine
at first, but over time, things will
start to get a bit muddier. You know the
numbers of the card types, which will be
helpful for some decks, but additional
information is hard to come by. What if
you need to know how much lowc cost ramp
you have to decide on how many higher
mana cards you can support? What if you
need to know how many cards allow you to
cast things from outside your hand for
the purposes of Flaming Tyrannosaurus?
What if you're trying to make sure that
you've got the right number of things to
slow down opponents and protect what
you've got? This is where categorizing
starts to become really useful. You can
lump a specific group of cards into
their own little bucket and keep track
of them that way. Though a lovely tool
on the surface, categories can range a
bit in their usefulness. They can be a
helpful tool in deck building, but they
can just as easily add more confusion
than they elucidate or even lead players
down unfortunate deck building paths all
on their own. So, in this video, I want
to talk about what categories accomplish
and how to get the most utility out of
them in deck building, as well as how
some people are setting back their own
decks by using them wrong. Before
bumming you out with that though, I want
to tell you about something exciting.
It's this video sponsor, Void Monster.
Voidmonster.org is a site created by MTG
artist Forest ML, who you may know from
the original docside, Rest in Peace, and
it features some really punchy,
evocative designs for trading card game
accessories. There's the awesome cycle
of mana symbol playmats, and there's
also an exclusive new drop once a month
that's available for a weeklong
pre-order period, but gone after that.
This month is the greedy drop, a pot of
greed shirt and playmat with an added
goldfoiled treasure token if you get
both. And you can pre-order that until
July 6th. You can check that out at the
link in the description. And thanks to
Void Monster for sponsoring the video.
Okay, so the first thing categories do
is capture the core tasks that the cards
in your deck are performing and allow
you to specifically look at these
subsets. I always start out with
categories of card that most decks will
want at least some of, principally
lands, ramp, draw, protection, and
interaction. These categories are useful
because all on their own, they start to
paint a picture of the shape of what a
deck is doing. If a deck runs a lot of
lands and ramp, I know I'm going to be
looking at a big mana mid-range deck
that's looking to outscale its
opponents. If I see a deck that's lower
on cards intended to interact with
opposing plays and higher on protection,
I know I'm going to be looking at
something that's faster and more
proactive. I'm going to get more into
constructing these categories and when
to break them up. But first, I want to
lay out a cautionary note. I've seen a
lot of guys recommending people include
a category such as theme as a discrete
entity alongside these other sorts of
function categories, at least in the
early stages of deck building. and I
simply cannot recommend that as a
general practice. This is a somewhat
misleading piece of advice because in
most successful decks, a large number of
these theme cards will also be
accomplishing the other core tasks I
mentioned earlier. Mana acceleration,
value generation, protection, and ways
to slow opponents. There may be some
cards that only do their theme, such as
one mana birds in a safara deck or
muroke lords in a hackball deck, but a
whole lot of other theme cards will
often be contributing to one of these
core categories. If somebody asked me
for healthy starting ranges for their
core categories for a bog standard EDH
deck, I'd say something like 35 to 40
lands, 15 to 20 pieces of removal
equivalent, 13 to 18 pieces of draw, 7
to 12 pieces of ramp, and 3 to eight
pieces of protection. What you may
notice about that is that if you go on
the higher end of each of these values
to be safe, that adds up to 98 deck
slots. You got a whole one left over to
work with after these core categories.
This is not to say that you necessarily
need these numbers in every deck or that
there won't be overlap between
categories, but the implication here is
that cards that don't fit into one of
these categories are inherently charging
your deck an opportunity cost, and you
should keep that in mind when deciding
how many of them to have. With that out
of the way for now, let's get into the
meat of these core categories because
there can be nuances in what a category
should cover. Lands are the simplest
because the deck building role lands
generally matches up one to one with the
card type of land. You can make an
exception for non- mana producing lands
such as glacial chasm or specific
centerpiece lands like Mesa's End since
these won't be producing mana as their
primary function. But for most other
cards, I keep them categorized as a land
first and foremost with any other
functions entered as subcategories I can
look at later. In this case, the utility
of including or excluding lands from
your lands category comes from in how
you use that category. As long as the
cards in your lands category are cards
that you personally consider a land
drop, you can do some math on the
resulting number and figure out how
successful you'll be at making it up to
your higher costed spells. Speaking of
which, let's talk about ramp. This is
one of the trickier core categories
because it can vary so much. Most decks
want some of it. Some decks want a lot
of it. A handful of decks won't want
much at all. So, when constructing your
ramp category, you should be asking
yourself, why am I ramping? If your ramp
is geared to hit specific cards a turn
early, you'll want to be specific with
the curve of your mana. And it even
might be worth including ritual style
cards that can give temporary mana in
some circumstances. By contrast, if your
ramp is generally geared toward
increasing the volume of your mana
without specific timing goals, less card
efficient options like smaller ramp and
ritual style cards won't make as much
sense, and bigger options will likely
work out. You'll sometimes catch me
saying something like, "Warn Power Stone
isn't a ramp spell if you're playing a
Cranco deck." because it's fun to speak
in cryp absolutes. But what I really
mean when I say that is that if your
acceleration category is mainly intended
to get you to four mana a turn early,
warn power stone doesn't fit that
function and thus probably isn't worth
playing unless you can find another
purpose for it. The same goes for
interaction, which I choose to define
here as cards that exist to set
opponents back in some way. The card
murder performs one game action,
destroying a creature. But this game
action can accomplish a number of
different tasks. Killing a big attacker,
clearing out a blocker, stopping a
combo, taking care of a value engine,
eliminating a stacks piece, and so on.
This fact gets a bit more puzzling when
we consider that there are lots of cards
that perform some of these tasks, often
better than a murder can, but can't
perform others. Fogs are great
defensively and even against some
combos, but they're useless for slowing
opponents down. Counter spells will be
good at protection and combo breaking,
but the timing will restrict their
usefulness in limiting opposing value,
and they can't deal with things already
in play. Your instinct might be to back
away from this fact and pretend it
doesn't exist. But for purposes of
categorization, all this means is that
in lie of perfectionism, we can focus on
building categories that are flexible
and work with our deck's needs. One
categorical starting point I've used
before is having two slightly fuzzy
buckets. Protection plus counter spells
and removal plus defense. This might
sound odd at first, but it makes some
sense if you think about all interaction
in terms of how proactive versus
reactive it is. Protection is very
proactive in the sense that it purely
supports your own game plan and involves
thinking ahead toward possible issues.
And counter spells are similar but with
a bit more flexibility to hit opposing
threats. Removal of all types will be a
bit more reactive since it gets played
after a problem card has resolved.
Though, since it can target value
engines, it could still play more of a
calculated long-term role in a deck.
Defensive cards like attack and damage
prevention are the most reactive in my
mind since they're a thing whose only
purpose is preventing a player from
losing. The final line of defense in an
EDH game. With these different types of
cards laid out, the two buckets approach
basically just draws an arbitrary line
somewhere in the middle of the spectrum
of tools. Though it might be useful to
get more specific. If you have a deck
that cares about a particular
interactive tool like defense or stacks
to hinder things that might otherwise
give you problems, give it a category.
If you have a deck that cares about
protection, definitely give it a
category. It'll be good to keep an eye
on. Putting this extra thought into
categories will also give you a better
idea of what your deck does or doesn't
need. I'll often include graveyard exile
in a removal stacks or general
interaction category because most decks
won't gain anything by granting this
necessary tool its own category. This
won't be the case for all decks though.
My Malfagore deck has three separate
categories for his interaction sweep
because they all serve different roles.
Discard effects put my opponents behind
in value. Removal deals with active
threats on the board. And graveyard
exile serves an unusually key role here
in preventing opponents with graveyard
oriented decks from getting use out of
the cards I'm causing them to discard.
On the other hand, if different
interaction pieces aren't serving
clearly defined roles that you want to
keep an eye on, it might be perfectly
fine to throw them together in the same
category. It all depends on how much you
care about distinguishing somewhat
different effects from one another. The
same is true for draw to a lesser
extent. If you have a bunch of normal
card draw in your deck, you might call
that category draw. If you add in some
handful of draw adjacent things like
Leia or Futureight, those are also
probably fine in the draw category as
long as you're not a quasa player.
Though you could also rename the
category to value or something. The name
isn't too relevant. What is relevant is
when different draw adjacent cards start
to perform different tasks. In my draw
video, I laid out that various things
that allow a player to see and play with
more cards can be placed along a
continuum based on how much of a
player's library they allow you to see.
In the middle is ordinary draw, seeing
as many cards as it acquires. And on the
edges are pure filtering spells which
generate no card advantage and pure
value cards which don't even interact
with the player's library. In some
cases, all of these can be lumped into
the same category. Tutors, card draw,
recursion, and so on. But other times,
different cards might start to take on
different roles. You might run tutors or
filtering spells to allow you to find
the tools to build up some sort of
central engine for your deck. And in
that case, you might want to keep the
digging cards and the value cards in
different categories to keep an eye on
how many of each you got. And that's
just a case where categories might be
nice. Depending on how you're building
value, it might be essential to lay out
more clear roles. Some decks might run a
bunch of draw, discard, looting cards as
their card selection to find what they
need, and also some recursion or other
graveyard synergies as their sources of
value to get advantage over their
opponents. In that case, those two
things are going to be playing quite
distinct roles in the deck to the point
where they basically become a whole
separate thing, a synergy package. This
is the second major thing categories do,
allowing people to keep track of
synergies. Specifically, for each
synergy package, I'll typically include
two categories, setup and payoff. As an
example, in a flicker deck I have, I
include a core cards category that
includes my three flicker engines plus a
card that increases the overall velocity
of the deck. And I also include a
category called m tasty slide that
features creatures with ETBs I might
want to repeat through flickering.
Relevantly, the former category is a
primary category because pushing my
flicker game plan is the only thing
these cards accomplish, whereas the
other category is a subcategory that I
don't need to see all the time. This is
because being flickerable isn't the
primary role of these cards. It's simply
an attribute about them. The fact that
they have an ETB that's useful to repeat
is only a relevant fact when I have an
astral sight effect available. And their
role is typically the same in either
case, just amplified if they're being
flickered. There might be other
situations where both setup and payoff
are in their own subcategories or where
these things are layered into different
categories. Whatever ends up making the
most sense to you. Regardless, the
utility that the categories are creating
for you in this case is allowing you to
keep an eye on how well supported a
specific theme is. It's easy to throw a
flicker thawsa into your deck after
spotting a couple cool ETBs or toss in a
fallor to go along with some cool
impulse draw effects. In some cases,
these payoff cards might have enough
support from other cards to feel
valuable, but in other cases, they might
not. If you don't maintain a setup
category for this synergy in your deck,
you might not even clock that this is a
problem and might presume that these
cards not working out in games is due to
bad luck. If you'd had that setup
category and noticed that you're only
running five pieces of impulse draw,
suddenly you'd probably be a lot more
vigilant of how these cards are doing in
games and more willing to re-evaluate
them. I will say that synergy based
usages of categories have become a bit
less necessary as deck builders have
picked up a particular feature, the
search function. If you're on architect,
you can throw a skyfall search in this
box here and it'll only show you the
cards in your deck that fit this search,
which is useful for keeping track of
something like my cycling cards in my
shroom deck. Moxfield has something
similar. There's this little highlighter
thing that you can throw some inputs
into and it'll highlight all the cards
that fit that definition. Either of
these might suit your preferences based
on what sorts of UI you like. But
something I like about Architect
specifically is how this works with the
maybe board of the deck. Sometimes if
I'm building a deck and I'm not sure
what direction I want to take it in, I
won't stop at categorizing what's in the
deck, I'll categorize my maybe board as
well. Often times, this category will
simply be the reason a card isn't in the
deck. A lot of times I'll have a too
expensive category if I'm building a
budget deck or a too slow category if a
card is a bit below the power level I
think I'm shooting for. This allows me
to have a suite of cards available to
peruse if I later decide to power up or
power down the deck. And it also acts as
a form of documentation of my thought
process that I can go back to. The other
type of maybe board category I'll
include is packages that I'm thinking of
adding to the deck but don't know if
there's enough support for yet, such as
ETBs or shamans. This is where the
search comes in handy. If I notice I'm
ending up with a lot of top of library
manipulation, I can plug a search term
like shuffle or library into the box and
I'll immediately see how many cards in
the different categories and maybe board
packages include that term. As a final
note here, searches won't always
perfectly capture the stuff that might
be included in a category. If I searched
enter into my Sharon slide flicker deck,
among the things that pop up would be
vidokul and aether mage and eagles of
the north, two cards whose ETB is
decidedly not the reason they're in the
deck. Still, search filtering is a
useful tool and I definitely encourage
checking it out if the deck builder you
use has it. So, I've laid out the main
two purposes for categories in my book.
Goofing your core categories to keep an
eye on the shape of your deck and
keeping track of your synergy packages
to have an idea of how thoroughly
supported different elements are. Some
people have a tendency to treat
categories as a means to appease some
abstract cardboard god, but truly
whatever works best for you in
conceptualizing your deck is the right
way to go. That said, before I get too
kumbaya with things, it's probably a
good idea to reiterate some best
practices for the average EDH player. I
laid out some examples of what you could
do or what you should do, but what
shouldn't you do? For one, putting cards
together in the same category that are
similar on some superficial level, but
very different in function. I don't have
an issue with combining somewhat
different effects so long as they
perform roughly the same function. So,
for example, expedition map and dark
ritual are very different effects, but
they share the functionality of helping
a mono black player build up some higher
costed plays, and that's a valid
category. An example of what wouldn't
work is putting Thalia, Guardian of
Thraban and Ghostly Prison together in a
stacks category. These cards both impose
taxes, but the game actions they tax are
basically polar opposites. Dalia is good
for slowing more technical decks and
giving the upper hand to a
creature-based game plan, whereas
Ghostly Prison makes attacking more
costly, but does absolutely nothing to
slow down anything outside combat. The
former is proactive while the latter is
purely reactive and merging them into a
single category is a recipe for
confusion. The other thing to avoid is
overcatategorizing. Basically creating a
category to track a type of card that
isn't actually useful to track. I'll
sometimes track life gain in my grindier
decks. And even though this category
often contains only a couple cards, it
still feels worthwhile because drawing a
piece of life gain in something like my
Malfagore deck typically feels like a
dramatic shift in the dynamic of the
deck. On the other hand, I would never
create a category like this for an
aggressive deck with a strong proactive
plan. Senu is a solid life gain engine
in my Yoshimaru deck, but the life gain
isn't why I added the card, and drawing
into a source of life gain doesn't
really impact the decision-making of
something that is first and foremost a
beatdown deck. The same goes for another
card in that Yoshi deck, six. I'd call
this a recursion spell generally, but
it's not in the deck because I need
recursion. It's in the deck because it's
a solid source of value that's also
legendary. In a different deck with
stronger graveyard themes, I might have
gone with a more specific category, but
in this deck, I've opted to stick it
with the next card draw where it feels
right at home. Now, these are instances
where categorizing a card differently
could add unneeded complexity to its
categories to overexlain what the cards
in the deck do. This is kind of a
problem on its own, but the bigger issue
with overcatategorization is when
categories are used to justify the
presence of cards that really might not
belong in a deck. Let's say I'm building
my Yoshimaru deck and I give Senu a
lovely little life gain category. Maybe
a bit unnecessary, but fine, whatever.
Now, let's say I see a soul warden
hanging around in a binder and decide to
give it a spin in the deck. And hey, we
can toss that in the life gain category
as well. Soul Warden is a powerful card
that can gain a lot of life, but it
doesn't do much in a legendary creatures
beatdown deck because life gain isn't a
priority there. Without the life gain
category, I'd be forced to look at the
card and go, "Wait, why is this here?
What is this accomplishing?" With this
category, I've constructed a
justification for this card out of thin
air and might choose to keep this
unnecessary card in my deck as a result.
This illustrates a side benefit of
categorizing a deck. Putting cards into
categories requires a deck builder to
think about why a card is there, and any
cards that didn't end up in many
categories immediately become suspect
and deserving of additional scrutiny.
This is one of the reasons I'm wary of
plan or theme categories. They give an
easy place to toss cards that might
otherwise seem out of place or
underjustified. The problem here is the
harmful mental shortcutting this
category enables, although it actually
doesn't have to. I was watching another
creator's recent video on categories,
and in that video, Commander Bomi is a
bit more sympathetic to a plan category
in general, but mentions a specific type
of card to keep an eye on. planonly
cards or cards that fit into a deck's
central plan or theme but don't
accomplish a whole lot else. I found
this perspective interesting. So, I
actually ended up recording a long chat
with Bomi where we compared and
contrasted our views on categories a
bit. And I think it's interesting to
consider how deck building style informs
what categorization practices end up
working out the best. You can check out
that full conversation over on my newly
created second channel, Salubrius.
Although, I've also included a portion
of that conversation starting now. They
know me as the guy that knows a lot
about magic and has a bunch of cards,
right? So, they're like, I pulled this
valuable card. Do you want it? And I'm
like, uh, sure, maybe. Depends. Like,
what do you want from it? Well, I would
like to trade for it. And I'm like,
okay, what cards are you looking for?
Well, I would like some upgrades for my
te deck. They're like, okay, Ghana need
to be a bit more specific. What are you
looking for? And that's where they
already stumped. They don't know, right?
They because they don't actually know
what they are even looking for. they
would struggle to just uh use a system
like you were describing.
Sure. Yeah. And I I get that. I
definitely I fairly oftenly play against
players who are at least somewhat new um
who've maybe been playing Commander for
uh two months, six months, some
somewhere in there, you know,
occasionally like new new new players,
but usually more more often it's going
to be the people who are kind of into
the format. Um,
for those people I almost want to say
ignore some of what I'm saying. But, uh,
I think where this sort of kind of more
intricate categorization approach is
helpful is just for identifying areas of
concern. So, if you are, you know, if if
you are taking the time to look at, say,
let's go back to like the the
cast from exile payoffs and uh exile you
may play cards. Th those two kind of
interlocking uh payoff and setup. If
you're playing with those, I think it's
useful to categorize those just so you
can have a sense of how large those
numbers are. If both of those numbers
are like 12 or like 10, then you are
going to be able to feel decent. But if
you have maybe like this is exactly what
I think is very helpful. And this is
something that I think so far you have
left out and I asked for it earlier.
You've just given me numbers, right? If
I tell a player, if you want to do a
synergy package for impulse drawing, you
got to need 12 cards. They can work with
that. But if you just say, well, you got
to feel it out. I don't know that that
doesn't mean anything that yes I I I
know people people probably it it is
more helpful if I can deliver numbers um
I don't necessarily think it's
appropriate to deliver numbers Oh.